Hello, everybody. My name is markiplier and welcome to catch your chance. Now. this is a game about
dating it's a little bit of a dating simulator where you're going to be going out on a lovely date and
Trying to score as high as you possibly can it if there's one thing markiplier knows about scoring. Oh
*Confused Mark sounds*
*Confusion intensifies*
*Confusion turns into laughter*
That's so weird...
That is...
okay, alright then ah
Smooth baby. Oh yeah, that was smooth wasn't it eh
You just wait til. I can see what you can see. What i can do with other parts of my body
I'm very nimble if you know what I mean
( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
*Slurp*
Excuse my drool.
"Scratch That Itch"
(High pitched) I don't know if I wanna...
Scratch that itch unless we're talking about the issues of love
And then I'll scratch it all day long and sorry get back in my HuniePop days
Just being a little too eager. If you know what I mean
Catch it. Oh yeah, you got an itch, baby. You got woo
Woo is it? Oh? I thought I thought that. I had an itch oh
I didn't know that-
I didn't know that you I know that you you needed an itch okay. I got one star
swoom
whoosh
Whoosh I don't know where I'm going with this one. Where are you are you taking me, okay?
I guess I don't need to how about, I just go straight for it. Hi-y ah
Excuse you
I'm good circle back. You scratch that itch
Cause I don't know what you want from me ah I don't want to scratch the wrong itch here
I'm a, teacher. I have a question
Scratching the itch. I don't know what you want from me. Okay if you if you if you if you don't, tell me
What to do here I'm on gonna have  problems, Oh?
Like oh I get it. Okay. I get it don't mind me and my stretchy arms. I got it
Hey move your legs there for a little bit Markimoo's got to make some undercover moves
Oh, yeah, oh
All right, that wasn't the right way to go, but get fair with me one more time. Not used to these control schemes
You're not gonna be used to it. I'm gonna be doing here. Oh yeah, you wanna little bit of me. I
Got hair in my eyes. uh oi Oh
Okay, I'm ready to scratch an itch wherever that itch may be
Well is it your (inaudible)
Well itches gets stitches and where's the origin of my arm here turn over
Uh-huh, you don't worry about it baby, I'm very stretchy so, you got any  questions about my stretchiness
Don't worry about it one whoo, baby. Wahoo. I got this impres-
I don't know if I want to impress my own mother. Mom if you're watching it this don't be very impressed
Is all I gotta say. Oh Impress her mom. Oh not my mom oh okay? That's fine
what, what, woah
Woah, woah he- woah
Oh ho ho ho!
Hey, whoa?
whoa
Excuse me. Sorry , let's try this again. Sorry. What dude why my mother? What big hair you got?
Well, woah, hey woah, Hey, you whoa-ah zan egg projectile were you ain't go and get me Mr.
bird butt not this time around oh
Thank you for the sweet accepting, got a lot of bird butts in your hair mama. I just got it. Hey
Come back here, no
ahhh
Her mom's not gonna be
Impressed and I just what's wrong anyway, let me try that again
I gotta get this I can't rest and until I really have impressed her mother
I got this I am the best look at me go, I am great
Look at me go ah  I'm  the best you dodging all over the place Miss me, bitch
Oh, no, you know
I am gonna be born that gets a little piece action from her daughter
Do da doodle do  don't ask question about how I do that gonna touch her on the arm right now
Doodle, doot, very impressive. I know that right wahoo indeed. Oh,wahoo indeed, when it comes in love
Markiplier is best
What you don't believe me?!
I don't know why you don't believe me tongue-tied is we gonna get it on oh is we is we gonna get it on? Oh?
Wow
Let's go home here right now tingle tangle my tongue your other tongue here. We go now ha ha ha ha ha
Dogde oh you thought you thought that's how it's gonna. Go well tricks on you. It's a penis. Yeah
I did it kidding. I said I did it. I did it. I did it. I did it. I did it
I am the master of love call me mark a lover master
Don't call me that actually that's a terrible name either way that was catch your chance, so I'll catch you on the flippety-flip
in the next video but before
That would have been a good transition is actually in the video, but here I go dragging it on just a little bit longer
So thank you everybody so much for watching let me know where you think of this down in the comments below
give me your sweet, sassy dating tips down there as well and
There you go
Almost  forgot to blow, almost forgot to B to blow that, but either way
Thank you all so much for watching and as always I will see you in the next video
Buh, bye